افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد تسعه اشخاص
بينهم خمسه اطفال في قصف منزلين بمخيم
النصيرات ودير البلح وسط قطاع غزه نتابع
هذه الصور لاثار القصف على مخيم النصيرات
قبل قليل والشهداء من هذا القصف العنيف
لمربع سكني كامل في مخيم
النصير عض
الله ط اواصل معهم
انتش علي احدى العالقات هنا في هذا
المنزل
حزرا
منزل عائله عقل تم
استهداف من قبل المقاتلات
تب اياكم هذا
الاستهداف
صيرات استهداف
منزل العائله عقل ومربع سكني كامل تم
استهدافه من قبل المقاتلات الحربيه عدد من
الاصابات وعدد من العالقين عدد من الشهداء
في هذا القصف الذي استهدف هذا نتابع
واياكم
هنا بالرا تحت هذا الركام يحاول الان
الشبان انتشال هؤلاء
العالقين من تحت هذا
الرك وين اله
وين محوره انتشال عدد من العالقين
راحه يا
[تصفيق]
شباب هذا المنزل منزل ئ
عقل تم تبه بشكل كامل من قبل المقاتلات
واياكم هذا القصف لمنزل عائله عقل في مخيم
[موسيقى]
النصيرات محاوره
انتشال عدد من الاصابات وعدد من العالقين
تحت اركام هذا المنزل
هذه
اللحظات تحاول انتشال احدى
الاصابات نتابع وازنا في
هذا عالقين تحت هذا المنزل المستهدف يعني
نحن تحت ركام هذا المنزل يعني في اي لحظه
من الممكن ان ينهار علينا سقف هذا المنزل
ولكن بعنايه الرحمن سنوصل الرساله للعالم
اجمع
قضاعه جرائم هذا الاحتلال الذي يقصف منازل
المواطنين الامنين وهم في
بيوتهم يامنون ويرتاحون في الليل الا ان
المقاتلات الحربيه تدمر كل شيء على رؤوس
هؤلاء
المواطن